n'en peut plus de voir son plancher
abîmé chaque fois qu'elle entre chez
elle en avril un dégât d'eau à endommagé
une bonne partie de son parquet le
propriétaire de l'immeuble à réparer
grossièrement les dégâts mais les ennuis
s'accumulent son appartement est infesté
de rats et de cafards sans compter son
poil qui ne fonctionne qu'à moitié
je n'aurais jamais imaginé vivre dans de
telles conditions au Canada dit-elle la
mère de famille d'origine jamaïcaine vit
ici avec deux de ses quatre enfants
depuis son arrivée au Canada il y a 13
ans elle paye plus de 1000 dollars par
mois pour son loyer
mais être incapable de trouver un
logement abordable
qui leur vient en aide à organiser une
manifestation devant le bâtiment dans
l'espoir d'attirer l'attention du
propriétaire de l'immeuble
Q resident Show qui se lancer de faire
les rénovations nécessaires alors que
nous étions en train de filmer des
résidences de son d'ailleurs rendu
compte d'une suite d'osées dans le
garage
ce sont des excréments mélangés à de
l'eau qui coule par terre 17 hommes
malgré tout cela les locataires de
l'immeuble ont récemment appris que Q
resident show a soumis une demande pour
augmenter leur loyer de 5 et demi pour
cent en 2023 soit 3% au-dessus de la
limite permise par la province une
augmentation normalement accordée par la
Commission de la location immobilière de
l'Ontario pour permettre à un
propriétaire de couvrir les frais liés à
des rénovations majeures
prennent leur responsabilité dans ce
résident
avoir contacté la ville de Toronto à
plusieurs reprises pour qu'elles fassent
pression sur cue resident shoul mais
sans succès l'entreprise
Q resident show elle n'a pas répondu à
notre demande d'entrevue il Sandrine
Williams Radio-Canada Toronto